there are countless ways our daily lives
have been disrupted by the pandemic and
one is how we get exercise with gyms
closed and classes cancelled you have to
be creative to try and stay fit and
determined Jim Axelrod has a look at how
some people have developed a whole new
quarantine routine protector Freshman
Fifteen not gaining that Kovach 19 means
confronting a new set of challenges like
working out where you are with what
you've got
exercise in this age of quarantine
requires some ingenuity it's not a lot
of nerve and perhaps a few extra tennis
balls around the world people are
getting it done with a little help from
their friends or in some lucky cases
their best friend over the years british
fitness instructor joe wicks has tried
it all to attract kids to his video
workouts it took him nine years to gain
800,000 subscribers to his youtube
channel and in the past three weeks
alone I've now got 2.2 million followers
and subscribers to the channel which is
mind-blowing it's just exponential
global growth fortunate would appear
favors the resourceful and certainly the
multitaskers who find ways not just to
stick to their routines but improve upon
them as well for CBS this morning
Saturday to see Jim Axelrod in Montclair
New Jersey I feel like I'm gonna have to
try some of those things because it is
tough for me to do this what are you
looking for that video we found some
amazing video out there somebody that
looked awfully familiar to us being look
at you with the ropes this is sent sent
privately among friends and now
distributed to the
[Laughter]
private in there I'll set my I'm not
sending my riding Tony you're gonna get
it big-time big-time